every rejection is just a test if you
want something ooh every rejection is
just a test if you want something 100%
And so when she rejected me I was like
yeah I want this book there's nothing
else out there like it that helps you
overcome your fear and helps you get the
business actually started and then
growing I wrote a blog post for Tim
Ferris site in 2011 D old school super
old school and it was like how to start
a million dollar business in a weekend
and it went super viral I've seen that
literally so many people holds them back
from success in business and in life is
the fear of asking if you don't start
you'll never get anywhere and if you
don't ask you'll never get what you want
no ask no yeah bloody hell that's good
[__] where most people are and where
they can be is actually closer than they
think where they are and where they
actually want to be is closer than they
think who they are and who they think
they could be is closer than they think
but they have to start what would you
mean everyone should be an entrepreneur
that's a pretty hot take it is the best
investment you can ever make that's part
one and part two is it's the best way to
learn about yourself and I don't know
any other way to get that he I love this
I believe money can buy happiness ooh
take H take coming it's going to get
spicy Noah welcome to Deep dive how you
doing excellent fantastic um for people
who might not know who you are can you
give us a quick Blitz intro who is no
Kagan and how did we end up getting to
know each other how did we end up here
man um grew up in the Bay Area was
worked at a cubicle monkey over at Intel
and then I kept starting all these
businesses and I was number 30 at
Facebook so I was very fortunate to work
directly for Zuckerberg got fired which
is a pretty popular story uh and then I
went to help start mint.com I was number
four there they sold for 200 million and
then I basically tried and failed so
many different times starting all these
other businesses until 2010 I start
apps.com uh number one side online for
software deals we basically promote
software deals for solopreneurs so
people with small businesses uh today
we're going to do around $80 million in
revenue bootstrapped and then have a
YouTube channel uh where I help
underdogs it's the people we help to
inspire them on their business Journeys
and yeah just wrot a book million dollar
weekend to help other people have their
own business Journeys and success I have
so much to talk to you about all right
um so we actually did we first I think
officially spoke in the pandemic three
years ago when you were on a deep dive
live stream on my channel and there were
like a few hundred to a couple thousand
people watching that and we heard all
about the Facebook firing story all
about the mint.com so I just want to
sort of I kind of want to assume people
have already seen that because I want to
launch straight into some some new stuff
that you've been working on how does
that sound yeah I mean it's it is
interesting because I think we think
everyone's heard these stories and then
sometimes you're like oh there there's
new people in these audiences and it was
it was special because I part of you
know the million dollar weekend is like
connecting with pre fluenc and I
remember some on my team I was like
there's this guy Ali abdall his Show's
like getting started but he seems really
interesting and that was Mitchell on our
team he sent me over Channel and that's
kind of how we started connecting yeah
he replied to one of my newsletters he
was like it was like Mitchell absum and
I was like because I've been following
your podcast in like 201 17 18 that kind
of era and then I was like oh someone on
no kagan's team watch reads my
newsletter that's pretty cool that's how
we got connected and now we're mates we
are mates and I just remember meeting
with you and I was just blown away like
I was writing down all the things were
you were talking about I was like okay
I'm going to do that I'm going to like I
still use app and I was just like I
don't know I was just like this guy's
impressed there's something interesting
happening with you and is it now like 3
years later almost four years later yeah
so we both go interesting places um why
is the title of your book million dooll
weekend what's going on there the taking
a step back uh I wrote a blog post for
Tim Ferris site in 2011 damn old school
super old school and it was just how I
started all these businesses and how
other people can copy my formula and it
was like how to start a million dollar
business in a weekend and it went super
viral and then um fast forward today you
know the title is just like million
dollar weekend anytime we mention to
people it's like oh that's good um and
so the idea was just like how do you get
something started in a very short amount
of time blog post worked we validate it
and now the title is uh what people
people like so broadly kind of people
can obviously read the book and they
should read the book to zoom in and find
out all the details but what's what's
the big picture here how how would I
start a million dollar business in a
weekend clearly have to do it would be
in a hotel room like we're now exactly
yeah I mean I think what's interesting
is that there's so many there's so much
content about how to start a business
yeah Tik Tok social media blogs books
like if there's so much out there how
come people have not done it that want
to do
it that's the question and so 15 years
ago I had a dream to write this book I
was with my buddy Adam Gilbert from my
body tutor and we're bikeing New York
and I was like there's just no book out
there that if I wanted to get started
without taking funding without spending
a lot of time without spending any money
there's nothing out there and so I
wanted to be able to put that together
and solve the actual hard problem which
is why aren't people being successful
yeah and there's basically just two
fears why most of the audiences that
want to start a business which I think
everyone should be an entrepreneur have
not done it yet and then the business
part is the other half of the book which
is like how do you validate your idea
how do you check the market size how do
you check your one minute business model
that part I find a lot easier it's just
the fears that are holding people back
from their success o okay this is
interesting because I also encounter
this problem a lot when I speak to
people who want to start a YouTube
channel or want to start a business and
I'm often surprised by how much of the
conversation is like therapy SL
emotional support rather than like okay
let's figure out the target market and
the competitive analysis and all that
stuff yeah what are the fears you you
said there were two big fears yeah and
so in terms of the business and we can
definitely dive into like checking your
business model checking the market size
finding your first customers and then
how do you scale that stuff to think
let's start with the emotional stuff
we'll come back to that back to this
stuff is and this stuff no one
recognizes how how afraid they actually
are uh of this they won't admit it
because they don't realize it they don't
even recognize it but the two ones and
they're gigantic once you overcome them
and there's fun ways to actually
overcome it and a lot people in the book
have done it then all the other business
is easy so the first one is the fear of
starting yeah and so the idea that we
need more money I need to watch more
videos I need to take another course I
need to find out more things to then
feel ready and there's never a ready the
right the ready time is right now just
like you talk actually in feel good
productivity it's like get going get get
your confidence through your action and
then the second fear that I have uh you
see a lot on my YouTube channel but I've
I've seen that literally so many people
holds them back from success in business
and in life life is the fear of asking
oh it's the fear of asking and so if you
don't start you'll never get anywhere
and if you don't ask you'll never get
what you want no ask no get you have to
go figure out how do I practice asking
because it's a skill and it's a skill I
I've seen as a kid it's a skill I've
practiced at you know through all the
millions of dollars we've done
throughout suumo through all the
businesses I've been a part of and so
how to do it in fun ways so that when
you get to the business stuff you're
like yeah I'm a starter I'm a starter I
do things right now not how that's like
one of the big takeaways in the book and
moving yeah moving into asking so you
can do challenges and things like that
to make it fun so as you get into the
business you're like all right I'm going
to you know we can talk about different
businesses that have been started from
the book uh it makes it starting the
business a lot easier one of the things
that I remember talking about when we
were doing a live stream three years ago
you said something about asking for
discounts at Starbucks or something and
I remember saying I'm literally sweating
even just thinking about that and after
we had that conversation I was I think I
was still working at the time and there
was a Starbucks on the way home on on on
the way to work and I would I would
always say to myself you you know
today's the day I'm going to follow
Noah's advice which I think Tim Ferris
also talks about this at some point yeah
and I i' I've literally never done it
before I I still to this day have not
done it you didn't do it no I I kept on
chickening out I'd go up to the counter
I'd be
like and then and then the fear the fear
of asking would get in the way what what
do you think you're afraid of I don't
know um rejection uh I'm afraid of like
I I can I can tell myself that like oh
you know it's it's I don't want to put
them in an awkward position because it's
like you know this poor Barista he's
only getting paid $5 an hour whatever
the thing might be I don't want him to
feel awkward but really I think I'm just
afraid of afraid of the rejection and
afraid of coming across as an
inconvenience as a nuisance and stuff
yeah does that Vibe with what people
told you that's that's why people have
not had success in business yet because
they can't get comfortable asking
getting rejected realizing it's okay
maybe it was the offer maybe it's not
the right person and then moving forward
to find someone you can help and most of
the time it's actually switching the
context so what you're thinking is it's
a bad thing to ask but what if you ask
for a sponsor for your show from notion
and you help them promote you're just
asking them for something that's
actually a good thing for them and the
more that you can actually switch that
mentality you're like oh [__] I could
start asking for a lot of different
things maybe a raise maybe a customer
maybe I ask a girlfriend you know
there's all these other things you can
start asking for and the reason I love
the coffee challenge is that it's a safe
way to practice asking they say no to
you when you ask for so when you go to a
coffee place or anywhere you go next
time I did it at the hotel room this uh
about an hour ago got to the hotel
friend desk I said can I have an upgrade
please for free and he looks at me like
what are you doing I was like yeah he's
like no it costs money I like okay
thanks right it's it's I'm still doing
it to this day and it's doing it in
these small ways you do it in business
but when you go and ask for the discount
it's just recognizing that once they say
no life goes forward and you can learn
you can get better and you get stronger
will you will you commit to doing it
mate I'm I'm feeling I'm feeling the
shaking I'm like tearing up even just
thinking like hearing you he hearing you
say this like what you're saying is like
touching a partt of me that has this
like primal fear of like rejection I
think fear of rejection fear of failure
all of those things we're all afraid of
it it doesn't go away I'm still afraid
and if you look at my videos it's like
asking private jets knocking on people's
doors doing it on the streets and I'm
still afraid one of the ways that may be
helpful for you to think about it is
doing like rejection
goals so just changing the again into a
game so instead of making it this big
ego hit cuz like yeah I'm still afraid I
have anxiety doing these rejections and
like going and doing it but I'm like all
right I'm going to go and get rejected
10 times on the street or I'm going to
try to go and talk to like two people
and then you do it and it's like okay I
hit my goal it's fine and guess what
throughout that you might actually get a
yes throughout that you might get a
discount throughout that you might get a
customer and so again take coming back
to it's like how do I get how do I
practice starting and then if I can get
better at asking now let me start moving
forward on these different business
ideas whether it's creating content
maybe it's a service maybe it's
e-commerce whatever that is bloody hell
that's good [__] I think one of the one
of the big areas in which I struggled
and to this day still do is uh sales
because before just before launching my
course 3 years ago the YouTuber Academy
I had this real fear of selling thing I
was no I can't I can't be seen to be
selling something cuz selling is bad
like I guess that's another thing you
you've dealt with how do how how how do
people think about selling being bad and
like how might we think about it instead
yeah I so with aba.com we have to go to
a partner and say we're going to promote
your product for free and we'll split
the money with you I think of selling is
helping you you have an association that
selling is a bad experience I'm thinking
like if I'm going to and I say hey you
have a product I can put you on appsumo
I'm like wow I'm actually doing you a
favor because I believe it's good for
you now when you're doing selling I
think there's there's a simple format
called lot it's listen options
transition and this is just a nice way
that when you're talking to someone you
could sell so we'll do a practice thing
sure if you're what if something you
sold your course yeah like all YouTube
of course so first listen to your
customer uh are you interested in grow
YouTube yeah how come you're interested
in grow YouTube oh cuz I've seen
channels like Al ABD I know K can
succeed and I know it's the thing that
could change my life and yeah I just
like the idea of doing it and then if I
if you were to get my course like what
would you hope to get out of it um I
know that you've kind of grown on
YouTube a lot over the last few years
and I'd be hoping to learning some I'd
be hoping to learn what are what's the
secret Source here like what do you know
that other people don't and then what
what would be an outcome so like if you
were able to take my course what would
be success for you and why would that
matter to you oh um I mean if I could
get to the point where I'm making enough
money to quit my day job then that would
be amazing for my life nice and and how
much money would you want to quit your
day job oh I think if I was making like
3K a month I'd be able to quit my day
job we'll talk about the freedom number
by the way that's a a separate thing uh
that's been critical in shifting
people's lives to be able to get their
own million dollar weekend so if I hear
you right it sounds like if you want
help on YouTube and what's been holding
you back from success on
YouTube I I honestly I really struggle
with consistency and I make a video uh
and then I have all these
perfectionistic Tendencies and I don't
want to release it and I feel this ick
every time I see the video and I'm like
it's not quite it's not quite right it's
not quite perfect got and that means I
only released three videos even though I
want been wanting to start YouTube for 5
is yeah so you've been talking about it
and this is something that maybe you can
do it in in a month or in this week and
change your life so it sounds like if I
hear you right you want to work on
consistency and you want to be able to
make $3,000 a month so if there's a
course that can help you accomplish
those things and it was only $500 how
does that sound to you I mean that
sounds pretty good but like I want to
know I mean surely the course can't
guarantee that I'm going to get to that
goal right yeah so if you pay today I
will guarantee within 6 months you will
get your $3,000 and you will be
consistent and if not I'll give you your
money back oh is that something you want
to sign up for right now yeah 100% sign
me
up okay interesting so as if we take a
step back in like break down the
scenarios what I'm trying to really do
is listen the option that I think is
solving so when I'm listening I'm trying
to get what's what's Ali's real problem
yeah and then I also want to understand
what it's worth to you right your
freedom number which is a number that I
believe everyone needs to figure out is
what's the number you need to be able to
do your own business the to be able to
quit your job mine was $3,000 so I'm
trying to understand your your your pain
of it I'm trying to understand the like
what's held you back the value to it and
then options like okay so I understand
your pain here's the option that will
solve it does that solve it you're like
yeah then I'm
transition I'd like to get your money
today in a way that will get you the
result because I'm solving the problem
that you have okay and then what people
will do here's what this is the this is
the the big like red flag timeout yeah
yeah send me more info oh yeah yeah you
know why don't you um I'll sign up when
the when the course is ready yeah yeah
I'll do that and so that's a rejection
and the more that we M came back
practicing rejection you're like okay so
tell me what would make this a
no-brainer for you today can you educ I
just love this is one of my favorite
lines I love to learn can you just tell
me why you're not signing up today oh
I'm not signing up because I don't have
the money right now I have this amount
of money okay so if we had a payment
plan where you could do $10 a month and
every month you're able to pay it off
does that does that work for you or only
pay if you pay half now and half on
success so it's more how are you trying
to understand the person to be able to
transition them to success for
themselves and a lot of times not
selling is powerful like hey I don't
think this is right for you I don't
think I can help you that's just as
powerful as making the
sale okay so kind of reframing the way
we think of selling rather than being a
a bad thing that I am making an ask or
like making an
offer instead of it being a bad thing is
being like thinking of it in terms of
I've got the option of helping this
person out it's a great you're helping
you're helping I think it's awesome like
I truly like million dollar weekend my
YouTube channel apps.com I'm like if you
have a software company and you want
customers I I truly believe it's my job
to tell you about
atsuma and if you don't if it's not ref
you that's okay but for someone who
wants promotion like let me understand
what your needs are and if it aligns
with what I can do yeah I'm going to
transition them to the next steps of a
sale what are some other areas of life
in which you have done or people that
you know have done the asking thing and
it's led to interesting outcomes yeah I
mean you look at some of my YouTube
videos specifically uh I said it's at a
private airport and I asked people if I
could get on the private Jet and I got
basically like $100,000 flight to
Boston that was a pretty good ask that
cool yeah you know and that what crazy
about that was that I only stood out
there for about 10 minutes yeah I didn't
like have anything flashy it was just
it's accessible for everyone I think
this is there's a misconception that
like oh because they have something or
they did no I just stood outside with a
piece of paper normal clothes on and
just ask people like hey can I come see
your plane I love to see your plane and
the reality is that when you start
asking for things you realize that
people are actually a lot friendlier
than you think too yeah so
a guy named Jake who read million dollar
weekend he's he exactly what you said
actually he's been wanting to start his
own business for two years 24 months
he's done nothing which is 99% of people
yeah right it's the same thing with
productivity like they want to do
something they want to do something but
they don't do it and so I was like Jake
let's do something now not how let's
just make sure we're going today let's
just do it right now let's call someone
with your business idea I won't won't
put it out with his business idea around
golf trips I'll leave it at that let's
call someone right now and see if
they'll buy your your golf trip and he's
you know it's
like he's like oh [__] really I'm like
yeah let's do it right now and he was
shocked how friendly someone was and how
excited they were to give him
money I know but we have this fear like
I'm bugging them I'm harassing them and
Jake was that belief in him of what he's
trying to offer was so exciting for
these other people and I have the same
thing when I'm I did another video where
I asked first class passengers yeah that
was good it's very uncomfortable because
if you say no to me you're sitting next
to me for the next 8 hours which most of
the people said no yeah but we create
the script in our head when we're doing
things that this about the other person
that's just not true because a lot of
people I did talk to were actually
excited and happy to chat with me like
there was an optometrist there was a
yoga teacher there's just a lot of
different people that actually were
happy to share how they got to first
class and how others can do the same and
that was just cuz asking that was just
because of an ask it wasn't anything
that the where most people are and where
they can be is actually closer than they
think where they are and where they
actually want to be is closer than they
think who they are and who they think
they could be is closer than they think
but they have to start you can't sit
back you can't watch more you can't
there's no more to learn a lot of times
it's about getting going so you can get
to that place so we've talked about
talked about fear of asking um can you
tell me more about this fear of starting
like if with asking like I I Feel the
fear of asking I don't think I feel the
fear of starting but I'm I'm I'm sure I
I I know when it comes to YouTube loads
of people have that fear of starting
yeah what's it like in in the business
thing like what stories are people
telling telling themselves most people
tell themselves they're not ready okay
they say they need they don't have the
right business idea have you ever talked
to people like oh yeah you you have your
YouTube account how many people say I
don't have anything to talk about on
YouTube yeah like 80% of them most of
the people yeah if they just started the
YouTube channel today right now like if
their dream is to be a YouTuber like
like we are or maybe have an e-commerce
business or maybe it's a service
business or maybe whatever it is it and
it doesn't have to be a millionaire it
could be a grocery nare to make grocery
money it could be to make $100 so you
can have a nice meal once a month the
whole opportunity is just getting going
and so what are ways that people can
just get going and stop being sideliners
is what I call them so one way to get
going is your freedom number your
freedom number is what you said which
what what is your what was your number
where you felt comfortable quitting your
your medical
job I F I felt comfortable taking a
break when that number was like 10K a
month yeah I I felt comfortable quitting
when that number was
100K that that's that's another episode
That's The Following episode but
thinking about okay it's actually
probably a lot smaller of a number to be
able to quit my job and have freedom
than I realize yeah I I realized like a
lot of the thing like in in reality if I
had a job that I didn't like and I was
able to make I don't know 2 or 3K a
month to pay my expenses in my rent and
stuff yeah that would be the perfect the
perfect number to be like you know what
screw this I'm going to do my own thing
yeah I mean it seemed risky to me to
have a day job it seemed not risky to
start my own business and everyone
should be an entrepreneur because being
having money and the ability to work in
hotel rooms or stay at home with your
kid which I'm looking forward to doing I
want that opportunity and that's
available for everyone it's not
exclusive but you have to get started
yeah what do what do you mean everyone
should be an entrepreneur that's a
pretty hot take I think everyone should
be an entrepreneur being rich is
great I don't know if that's a hot take
anymore I don't know if you're allowed
to say people should be rich or not rich
but I've been poor for a long time and
I've lived poor for a long time and the
reality that everyone it's accessible to
everyone to be rich and being anre is
the best return on getting rich Let's
Take just like Zoom back for a second
what's the great stock market return
annually the 8% whoa okay real
estate 10% 7 15% and you have to put
money down and all this stuff yeah uh T
bills or interest bills 5% what else
government bonds yeah government bonds I
don't know what you guys have in the UK
7% previously 0% yeah okay
entrepreneurship unlimited yeah not not
even saying books I'm saying if you
start your own business there's
literally no upside to what you can
create yeah it is the best investment
you can ever make is starting your own
business and that's part one and part
two is it's the best way to learn about
yourself learning how to start and being
overcoming some of the fear you have
like what happens when my friends say no
to my business what happens that I I
start it doesn't work but I keep going
and I find that I have courage and I can
do these things exactly and you start
realizing like and I've learned more
than through business by myself than
anything else and you realize like I
have a lot more capable and a lot more
able to do things than I realized and I
don't know any other way to get that
that I've seen as effective as one as a
return on investment but secondly just
as a return on yourself what about
people who say you know there there'll
be some people listening to this and
think screw this guy like not everyone
should be an entrepreneur what if I like
my day job and I don't want to deal with
the stress of being an entrepreneur and
I just want to go home go to work
collect the paycheck and come home and
then spend time with my family yeah I
think they can do that and be an
entrepreneur okay and to be an
entrepreneur it does I think where
there's a misconception is to become a
milli millionaire you have to make a
dollar and that's where people get hung
up to become a millionaire you have to
start with
making1 and Everyone by the way can
right now on their phone message someone
to get a dollar just right now right now
right now they can message someone but
to start you have to get to become a
millionaire which is what people like oh
I want to be a millionaire no just get a
dollar and get going and that's how you
become a millionaire a multi-millionaire
or billionaire now to be an entrepreneur
I think where're people have the
misconception is well I need to make a
lot of money to be an entrepreneur I
need to make a millions or no you can
make a hundred bucks a month m doing
cookies like there's a woman Jennifer
who's R million dollar weekend out in
Dallas she's a school teacher and she's
like I just want to make a few extra
dollars a month for my family and so the
ability to have creative control the
ability to to create things with your
hobbies and your free time I think
that's what people all should be doing
and if they don't like it fine you don't
have to but I think one you got have a
lot of upside with the money if that's
what you want as well I think you're
going to learn more doing that than
anything else oh interesting okay so
you're defining how how are you defining
entrepreneur then how do you define
productivity I productivity in a very
holistic way almost too holistic some
some might say I think Entre in the
simplest form yeah H I believe it's just
it's someone who creates yeah someone
who
creates so that doesn't mean it has to
be making so much money I think that's a
big misconception of the more mentality
we live in yeah like how many
subscribers you want more how much money
you want more how much food you want
more it's like no I want a little bit
and I'm okay with that and that's
amazing a power of Entrepreneurship that
that's accessible to anyone anywhere
especially now now it's easier than ever
to start a business so would do you say
like you know back back when I was in
school I was freelancing as a web
developer yeah on the side does that
count as entrepreneurship or is that
like a different kind of thing is that
not what we're talking about here that's
exactly what we're talking about okay I
think it's expressing yourself finding
out who you are through
business that's nice I like that yeah
it's great I mean and it's accessible to
anyone and it doesn't have to be there's
not a set way of doing it like on my
YouTube channel there's a guy Larry
janeski he does $600 million a year with
basements Bas I don't I've barely ever
been in a basement I don't know if you
guys have them in the UK but in
California we don't or there was a woman
Pam uh we knocked on her door just
knocked on her door she's doing
strawberries strawberries and now wine
that's how they got rich and it doesn't
mean you have to get rich even though
being rich is great and I would
encourage everyone to do it I really do
yeah but just finding some activity and
hobby that you're really interested in
for yourself that gives you something
creatively as well as an upside that's
that's unlimited okay so it sounds like
you're saying that like even if someone
has a day job then they can learn a lot
about themselves and they can get some
extra pocket money by doing something on
the side whether it's baking cookies
selling strawberry selling wine or
starting a YouTube channel doing web
development and eventually the people
who get going are the ones who then have
the the option of taking forward if they
want have you ever been fired have I
ever been fired no I've never been fired
what's it
like that was good that was good that
was good that was good um you realize
that everyone is replacing able and you
don't have as much control on your life
as you think and especially today where
interest rates are high there might be
coming down mortgage rat all over the
place companies are back are cutting
back I think now more than ever people
need to figure out for themselves how to
at least have that option available to
them whether you work at atsuma we have
a lot of people with their own business
at appsumo we encourage it but in other
companies like if you have a day job
that you like like they could still get
rid of you at any moment any moment yeah
there's no obligation to them and so
having your own option that you've
created that you have one it's fun at
least gives you that option so that if
things don't go your way you're in
control of something nice M I love this
I'm fully fully on board with with with
with what you're saying I think in the
past I've been hesitant to say everyone
should become an entrepreneur because
I've always got the thing of like well
what if I enjoy my job and and all this
kind of stuff and I've always said that
like well okay but wouldn't it be nice
you know a lots of people in the
pandemic lost their lost their jobs yeah
and wouldn't it be nice to just not be
so reliant on a single employer because
when you have a job you're ring on a
single person to pay your paycheck and
to support your family and that person
is not you that person is your boss or
your boss's boss or the HR person or the
person doing the company and you never
know what might happen um and so I've
always been very bullish on people
learning skills on the side and then
trying to find a way to monetize those
skills yeah man you just learn so much
about yourself you learn so much it's
fun it's fun I mean if you the
difference in in in what I believe
million dollar weekend process is it
should be fun and I talked to to someone
who read the book and and I asked him
like what about a million doll weekend
what is it that you wanted like I didn't
want to live a wh if
life I didn't want to leave I didn't
want to live a wh if life I wanted to
know that I have dreams that I of how I
want to spend my day which is with his
kids yeah and I didn't want to not be
able to take that chance now and show
and lead by example showing the kids how
he is so that he has that opportunity
one day in the future but you'll never
get there unless you start yeah and then
sticking with it which is law of 100
which is like doing these things and
sticking with these things what do you
mean what's low of 100 so you've started
YouTube you've started a business
most people quit too soon yeah you've
seen it all the time I see it all the
time and so as we start these things and
we make a little bit of money yeah how
do I stick with it so love 100 is how do
you apply to 100 days or 100 videos or
100 emails or 100 calls whatever it is
for me it was podcasts I quit too soon
and I had I was basically getting tons
of downloads per episode but because it
wasn't it was 30,000 downloads and it
wasn't 100,000 downloads I quit at
around 40 down uh 40 podcasts if I would
have just stay
and so I've noticed this trend where the
people who are most successful started
and they need some framework to stick
with it so for me it was this law of 100
to actually be able to stick with
YouTube now three years and then
continuing I'm now on a 10year plan for
YouTube and so just finding that people
need a framework to be able as they
start something now okay let's call One
customer day don't make it a big thing
just first if you have a day job and you
got kids and you got a family that's a
lot going on one call a day one social
post a day one email a day whatever it
is just pick a hundred of them and then
stick with it this episode of Deep dive
is very kindly sponsored by by hostinger
now if you're looking to start a
business or develop some kind of brand
then you're probably going to need a
website and if you've ever wanted to set
up a website but you're not sure where
to start then hostinger has everything
you need hostinger is a top Global
website hosting service with servers all
around the world it's fast and it's
reliable and it's got over 2 million
users and it's becoming one of the
fastest growing web hosting Services out
there now I personally really love
hostinger because it is so easy to use
and it's fantastic for me and fantastic
for my team because we don't have to
deal with too much faf and too much
setup and if you're new to website
design they've also got everything you
need to build your website rather than
just to host it and recently they've
added a really cool AI website builder
which lets you build a sort of
professionall looking website or at
least the first draft of it in literally
seconds it is super easy to use there is
a drag and drop editor that lets you
customize stuff and you don't need to
have any coding or like CSS HTML
knowledge at all hostinger comes to less
than $3 a month and that includes a free
domain name as well so it's super
affordable and if you use the link in
the video description so hostinger.com
Al abdal and on the checkout page you
type in Ali abdal in all caps then that
will give you 10% off your plan as well
so thank you so much again hosting for
sponsoring this podcast this episode of
Deep dive is very kindly sponsored by
snipp now snipp is an amazing app that's
absolutely going to revolutionize the
way you listen to podcasts I've been
using it for the last 2 months and it's
become my absolute favorite way to
listen to podcast because the cool thing
about snip is that it's not just a
podcast player what it does is allow you
to create Snips of each podcast that you
listen to where if you hear something
that particularly Vibes with you all you
need to do is tap your headphones and
the app will save it and then it's like
this ridiculously fancy AI transcription
type feature that will listen to the
last like minute of the podcast it will
figure out what's being said and it will
create a little snippet or a little snip
where it will summarize and it will give
you like the notes from exactly what was
said and then you can click edit on it
and you can like set the start point and
the end point it's basically like being
able to highlight a podcast as if you
were reading a book now this is really
helpful if you want to remember the
kinds of things that you hear in
podcasts and it's also really helpful if
like me you are some sort of content
creator and you benefit from sharing
your insights with other people which
even if you're not a content creator
it's just a nice thing to do generally
and the other cool thing about this
Snips feature is that you can see where
other people have snipped a particular
podcast and so you know we all have way
too many podcasts to listen to these
days but you can browse through and you
can see o that episode of Deep dive was
snipped 4,000 times and that one was
only snipped 2,000 times so you know
what let me prioritize listening to the
one with 4,000 Snips because more people
have highlighted it and then you can
even browse through the highlights so if
you haven't got time to listen to the
whole podcast you can go through the
various Snips and you can decide is this
podcast worth you listening to and
because it's a powerful AI tool it also
generates transcripts and chapters for
basically every podcast which means even
if the podcaster hasn't like created
those chapters already they'll
automatically create them using the AI
features and so you can again skip
around in podcasts to the various bits
that might interest you the most and
actually it turns out that deep dive
listeners already love using snipped
because we are actually the fifth most
popular podcast on the snipped platform
so if you want to give it a go and you
want to level up your ability to listen
to podcasts and take notes at the same
time then head over to sn.com deepdive
that's
snpd snpd like snip with a d on the end
of it sn.com deepdive and that link is
going to be in the show notes and also
in the video description if it's easier
for you to click on it and if you sign
up via that link or that URL in the next
month then you will get a completely
free 30-day trial of snipped and then
you can try it out for the entire 30
days and you can take all these notes
and you can see if it Vibes with you so
thank you so much snipp for sponsoring
this episode when I started YouTube in
2017 I told myself my first 100 videos
are going to be crap so I'm just G to
get through the first 100 videos and
then I'll reassess and how'd that go
make video number 52 I hit 1,000
subscribers video number 82 went viral
and video number 82 took me to like
10,000 video number 93 went viral took
me to 50,000 and by the time I got to
100 videos I was on like I don't know 50
58,000 subscribers and I had no idea
that that that's what was going to
happen I just knew that I've got I'm G
to do at least 100 videos yeah I I think
where where most people are are finding
their mistakes is is that they're not
starting it yeah like my first YouTube
video uh you can go on the channel and
see it it's me shirtless which is not
impressive I'll tell you that it was
just me shirtless in my room yeah doing
this with the same phone that everyone
else has I just posted it very little
and I got a little bit of response got
300 views and it was like oh I like
doing this and so it doesn't mean you
should just do things you hate and stick
with it forever but find something you
enjoy and so that I did that and then I
was like oh this is kind of fun and
people like it and so my point for
everyone is it's accessible you don't
need thousands of dollars a camera or
fancy microphones or lighting you just
need your phone and getting going and
then sticking with it now you know the L
I just bought like a this A7 S3 is a
$3,000 camera you have lenses these mics
are hundreds of dollars and that but
that's over time right same as your
content but you got started stuck with
it and as you stick with it it keeps
improving the first Vlog that I made I I
was watching Casey neistat's Vlogs and
Peter McKinnon's Vlogs in 2017 I was in
Cambodia on my medical elective where I
was doing like this plastic surgery type
stuff and I remember thinking I should
start a vlog and I remember thinking I
need to do it right now otherwise it's
not going to happen so I took out my
phone I lay on the bed and I said guys
I'm starting a vlog and I the video is
still on the Channel people watch it
people comment on it to this day that is
awesome where I'm like I know I I knew
that if I you know I had to just get
started like this I I had a camera but I
was like if I wait to set up the camera
it's just not I I need to take action as
soon as I have the inspiration and that
video is on the channel and that was the
start of my Vlog which was the start of
my YouTube channel being something about
something other than how to get into
medical school which you know now I have
seen your day in the life few years ago
Vlog where you had medical school
walking around with your camera I was
like this pretty good video but we've
had we do um a lot of beta testing with
the book yeah and so we've had we have
1,200 people in our beta team and every
weekend I go uh with five people to the
book and then we survey and we survey
okay what's what's your biggest takeaway
of the book and EV by far the number one
thing is the now not how a mindset and
it's this mindset of how do I just do
this thing right now you want to post a
video great you want to sell someone
great you're interested in maybe selling
cookies even post it on social media
right now now not how just message your
mom message your cousin message whoever
some maybe it's a colleague whatever it
is and you start realizing you can apply
this in kind of small ways like I don't
want to take out the trash well what's
now not how just go and take your trash
out right now that's obviously like a
silly way yeah but then you start
thinking in in wanting to start a
business or wanting to start a Content
Channel okay I have to I want to put a
video but I don't know I'm talk just
talk about anything doesn't even matter
just get it
out yeah this is exactly what we saying
our um YouTuber foundations course which
is a course for complete beginners
getting started with YouTube yeah and
like the third or so lesson in that is
me being like okay you're you're not
going to take out your phone you're
going to hit record and you're going to
talk to it and say why you're starting a
YouTube channel and you're going to up
on the YouTube app that's on your phone
and you and you're just going to do that
right now and so many people their first
YouTube video has been just that one
where they're like yeah I'm making and
they always title it Ali abdal made me
do this or some [__] Al like hi I'm
taking Al abd's course he made me do
this I've been wanting to start a
YouTube channel for 10 years and I
haven't done it but finally I'm going to
take action and I'm I'm doing the thing
and just reducing the friction lowering
the bar and just making it happen I
guess two questions for you one what
would you tell yourself when you were
first starting now to kind of be like
the now not how and then how just Frank
how grateful are you that you got
started mate I think I I didn't have the
terminology for that but I'd been
absorbing the Tim Ferris personal
development world so long that I knew
that like because I wanted to be a
YouTuber since like 2010 and it took me
until 2016 to make one video and then
until 2017 to actually start actually
commit to the decision of making YouTube
videos because I was thinking I want to
be a music YouTuber and every summer
like I had these friends who were good
at singing and I was like I want to
learn the piano and the guitar and we
were like like no but we we haven't got
the right equipment this was like three
phones but actually my brother had a
camera we could have just filmed with
that it could it would have been so easy
but I was like No And I I need to have
the perfect microphone I need to have
the perfect setup and obviously I can't
I can't do any of this until I have the
perfect setup and I waited seven years
to start make to make my first YouTube
video and in that in that time I
absorbed a lot of this personal
development stuff and I realized this is
a dumbass attitude let me just make
bloody video and I am so immensely
grateful every single good thing has
happened in my life as a result of
starting the YouTube channel seven years
ago it's insane
yeah like half the friends I've got now
are friends I've made through the
internet probably more than half my
relationship I got in through the
internet in a roundabout way all the
money that I've ever made has been
through the inter it's just [__]
incredible like how much that one
decision to start has just changed the
trajectory of my life and that's what's
holding people back and then you know
you have ideas you validate and then you
grow it if you can just get past
yourself then getting the business stuff
is easy but it's getting that stuff
going I think there's also this other
comment of how can like I'm so grateful
I want to thank my 13 year 13 years ago
self you're thanking your seven years
ago self I think for everyone out there
like what five years from today self are
you gonna thank for what you're doing
right now what are you GNA thank
yourself today in five years you're like
oh I'm so glad okay I just finally
started the thing I've been talking to
my friends about I've been thinking
about I finally just got going and in
five years they be like like even now
I'm so grateful 13 years ago I just got
going with absum yeah so lucky so
grateful that I started it and stuck
with it
yeah this thing I I really like this
framework of like what would you be
grateful for for yourself now five years
from now um I I used it uh a few years
ago I I I I had this like hole in my
teeth and my smile wasn't very nice and
I was it was a decision to get
Invisalign okay and it's it was a
process that was going to take two years
and I kept on putting it off because I
was like oh no but like they say you
can't drink coffee and I was working at
the time and then the pandemic hit and I
was like you know what now I have no
excuses now I need to get invis
years later my teeth and now I look at
my old videos I'm like similarly I
started taking some meds for my hair
loss like in like 2019 when I had almost
no hair and I was like two years from
now I'm going to be grateful for this
decision and that was the thing that got
me to take those meds and so I think
this this idea of now not how applies in
like so many areas of life this thing of
what can you start today that your
future self would be grateful for 100%
whether it's taking care of your health
or like calling your mom more often or
like starting that business or starting
that channel whatever the thing might be
I think we're we were surprised about
it's not as hard as we thought yeah like
oh if I finally you know all these
people are going to say this all these
voices that we have in our head which
everyone has like you still have it I
still we all have it but you get going
and then you actually realize through
action you get
confidence through practice you get
confidence and you kind of keep
practicing you keep going you're like
huh I actually can do these things but
that it's by getting into the game into
the arena starting that you can then get
to these other places yeah I I really
like an the the idea that confidence is
domain specific like you can have a CEO
who's super super confident in the
boardroom but who's really unconfident
when he goes to a nightclub because he
hasn't put in the Reps it's a domain
specific you can get someone who's like
incredible on stage but sucks talking to
a a camera when making a YouTube video
because confidence is domain specific
and that means if you're not if you're
not confident at something that's okay
you just haven't put in the Reps yet so
you can just get started and start
putting in the Reps and you can think
about something you are confident with
and think were you born confident that
thing or did you just practice quite a
lot and usually it's like I practice
quite a lot to become confident the
thing I that's a great point yeah mate
some good stuff um I want to talk to you
a little bit about the again it's it's
feels like a bit of a hot take to be
like being being rich is great because I
think the narrative that we're told and
and you know I I speak to a bunch of
people who are very rich and they're
always like yeah but like Beyond a
certain point money doesn't really buy
more happiness and you know all that
kind of stuff often the people I speak
to are like high-flying entrepreneurs
who have sacrificed their health and
their relationships for the sake of
making more money yeah so how do you
think about money and the acquisition of
of more wealth
I believe
no it's get spicy I believe money can
buy happiness okay I agree just tell me
more so my taking a step back I I do
believe a lot of people when they're
born in a certain class economically and
this is what I believe are believing
that they have to stay
there I grew up middle class so I stay
middle class that's how I felt I felt my
parents had normal jobs my dad was an
engineer and my mom was a nurse and I
was like I guess that's just where you
stay and realizing there's all these
levels to life and realizing you can do
any kind of life you want there's no
there's no rule to how you live it's how
you ever want it I remember as I'm
dating this Venezuelan woman and she's
in Spain and I kept thinking I I don't
know but that's not part of like the
normal plan I had this buddy tinan who
you know I love tinan he's like you make
the rule you create it and money which
is available to everyone sometimes it's
harder depending on how you were born
and how were certain situations but it's
available and you can create it and I
just lived so middle class and poor uh
basically until Co I was a multi multi-
multimillionaire and then when Co
happened I was just realizing like holy
[__] like I have all this money and I've
worked so hard to get it I'm just not
enjoying it and I started uh testing it
so one of the things about being an
entrepreneur is that we make it so scary
we're like oh it's oh my God it's this
big ass thing you have to quit your J
job don't quit your J job that's risky
yeah having a j job you hate that's also
risky yeah but start testing things out
and so I started experimenting enjoying
money I started experimenting like can I
buy happiness with money because I was
told that you can't like that's what
they say and I was like let me let me
question this thing and um I started
renting like I rented a Malibu beach
house for 25k and I was like oh yeah
money can definitely buy happiness okay
then I rented another house in Austin on
the lake that was 7,000 it was
everything was Cheaper by the way during
Co and you know if you want
million-dollar experiences you could I
rented a Lambo here in LA
uh a few years ago during that that
experience for $250 on turo oh it was
great that's not bad and I was like I
don't give two shits to have a Lambo
yeah you tested it out and realized you
didn't want it I didn't yeah I
experimented and I think if you can
think of how how do I have an experiment
or mindset in these different areas of
life huh maybe I can experiment being
rich see if I actually like being rich
maybe I can experiment having a six-pack
which everyone has and see if you
actually won I've had a sixpack I'm like
it sucks I like drinking and eating I
don't want to live that life and
actually enjoying the money now I'm like
this is so great not worrying about
which groceries I have to buy yeah going
to a store and it's it's crazy CU right
now it's a scary hard time for a lot of
people like you go to the grocery store
you're like you want to buy these things
you're like I don't know if I can get
all that you want to fly somewhere I was
talking to someone recently they're like
yeah it's expensive to get flights I was
like oh really and I don't mean that as
an arrogant thing or that I'm totally
disconnected from reality but the idea
of starting your own business being an
entrepreneur having money and you have
these choices that you can do anything
you want and if you want to work all day
great or for me as I'm having a family I
now have the ability to spend money to
have a lot of my free time like I can be
everyone can be a time
millionaire and money makes that a lot
easier and so I can have staff which I
don't want to have staff do everything
for my child but I can have do some
things so I can do some hard parts and
then enjoy the other parts that I want
so taking a step back at least create
your own business so you have this
option and if you're like I hate all
these money things and you did the
experiment and you don't want to do it
fine give the money away or just go do
whatever thing you want to do but I have
found like I I can do just so many
different cool things for myself that
it's accessible to everyone like I can
have two two bikes that are very
expensive here and in Spain so I don't
have to worry about which bike I'm
riding yeah and it's just so great I'm
so much happier having money and it is
you know Chris Williamson I think you
know Chris he had this thing it's it's a
bias right because I have money now but
I remember having no money and I was
sleeping on floors for a year I was
sleeping on my parents couch last night
and it brought back memories of it of
just working so hard and not enjoying
it I was just on there's a guy pach and
then I was living on uh shyan's her
couch and it was just like these really
tough times and I was making okay money
and it was it's like wow having money so
that I can hire coaches hire having
money so I can hire therapists and feel
better about myself and all these things
that open up to me is just what everyone
should
do and it's again I have to say it's
available it's not some exclusive Club
yeah so many people get rich from doing
stands from bottle caps it's not only
making a YouTube channel or doing e
Commerce you can do a restaurant you can
do a lot of different things it's just
finding the thing you actually
enjoy yeah I think when it comes to this
money thing a lot of
times and as as I'm saying this I think
I think I do this to myself even now
which is I think people tell themselves
a story
that they feel becoming rich is or let's
say I don't know even getting an extra
5K a month that to them feels
unattainable and therefore they tell
themselves I don't want it anyway why is
people if you just gave people 60k an
extra 60k for the year like a raise
they'd be over the moon if the boss just
gave them a 60k raise but if you say
would you like to build a business on
the side that that makes you 5K a month
and if they think it's un unachievable
they'll say oh I don't want that anyway
oh people oh who who needs money money
like you know money doesn't buy
happiness and like the real things in
life are you you know relationships and
health and that is also true to an
extent yeah like I don't think I'm am
that much happier as it were right now
than I was when I had a lot less money
I'm happier in the sense that I'm not
doing my day job which was the thing
that was bringing me unhappiness and so
money allowed me to have that option and
I'm quite a risk ofers guy so I needed
to I literally needed a million in the
bank to feel comfortable quitting my 40K
day job uh to feel like you know that
was a you know a risk worth
taking but I think there's this story
that a lot of us have and even even now
like you know we'll do I don't know 5
million Revenue this year with like 60%
margins and Sam par from my first
million was challenging me this morning
he was like what what do you really want
like what's your goal for growing the
business and was like uh I don't really
have one I just want to make content and
like teach and stuff and I think that's
true to an extent but I I always wonder
am I just am I afraid of trying to go
for 10 million Revenue am I afraid of
trying to go for like the bigger numbers
yeah or is there something like I I also
think there's something to the fact that
I love what I'm doing and I don't want
to I don't want to do not fun things for
the sake of more money does does any of
that make sense like yeah yeah how do
you square those things a few different
things so part one is once you have your
Freedom number which yours was $10,000
mine was $3,000 and everyone should
figure out what's your freedom number do
something you actually enjoy to get that
freedom number yeah and if it's cookies
for me it was promoting stuff I love
promoting that's what ABS was and then
it was like all right I'm going to do
this thing and enjoy it and then it
turns out it can actually make millions
of dollars which we go through a million
dollar weekend which is like all right
what's your Market yeah making sure you
the right Market making sure you have
the right business model so you can
actually using your freedom and do the
things you enjoy now in terms of your
second question I think that that's
actually a problem it's the Valley Tech
Bros which I I come from but I left I
went to the Midwest and now Europe I SP
a lot of time in Spain it's the problem
is that they're just having more for
more
sake and they have not realized like
when is it enough like this year uh
absum did around $7 million in profit
which is insane it's insane like I was
happy with 36,000 a year yeah and that's
profit
and I'll just be super canid I can take
all of it yeah I can just take that
money and just like put in my bank
doesn't like there's some amount at a
few million dollars where it's enough
for me so let me give it to the team
which we did let's take everyone to
Mexico which we did let's go invest in
servers let's go invest in ads let me
give it to my business partner and it's
recognizing and when it's enough for
what how you actually want to live and
that's the power right you you talk to
certain
people I think that's what they think
they're supposed to be selling telling
you yeah oh you're supposed to grow
super fast and you know what it's like I
actually want to spend if I can spend my
whole day making sure I'm good parent
and a good partner and do my work like
that to me is ideal I'm not willing to
sacrifice that just to make more money
for more sake like we we had a board
meeting and I love our board members
because they challenge me it's like
Andrew Chen who's awesome rajer T smer
from indeed we got Moody from glasto and
zapier he's amazing and they're like
you're not growing fast enough and I'm
like we're actually trying to grow
slower we're trying to grow slower for
longer and it's just and all that is is
coming back into yourself but what I've
noticed for me and I think for everyone
out there set less less ambitious goals
that's I talk about in book set less
ambitious goals is what you talk about
in your book and if that you can sustain
you set in your book LeBron James is the
slowest Walker one of them in the NBA
and he is literally you know what 20
years in the NBA and so with appsumo the
I love our board members and we and
there's things to take away from how
they challenge us and everyone should
get a board or Elite advisers which we
can talk about but we're going to grow
at 7% next year that's our goal and
people are like 7% like yeah that's like
you're going to go you're going to go to
sleep like you're going to even try but
what we have noticed is that I I don't
want to sell I don't want to go public
cuz I like I like what I get to do I
don't have to have a job yeah and by
having less ambitious goals we can have
more freedom we're not stressing to make
money and that leads us to more
creativity which then ultimately leads
to a more successful business from a
money and frankly enjoyment perspective
and yeah that has been a
counterintuitive thing that I've learned
over the years of running different
companies where I used to set like if
we're not 10 Xing this year then we
failed which is what our advisor say and
so I do think there's ways of doing that
which is doing it in smaller segments
but again coming back to how you
actually want to live your life and
operate your business and yes make a
million a year two million a year it's
way more than enough for almost everyone
but at least get to that point that you
can have that option but then I think if
you have to try to go super fast H okay
uh it's way it's unnecessary it's not
necessarily what you want so it sounds
like you also agree that at some point
there is diminishing returns to more cap
to more money 100% it's just that the
study from 20 years ago might say it's
70k but you and I probably say in in the
range or something yeah and everyone
who's like I want to be a billionaire
[__] like who cares to be a
billionaire like what are you GNA do you
want to donate all go donate all yeah
like oh if I help a million people it's
like do you really want to help a
million why I help one and start right
now to help one what I've recognized
though is that 70,000 today people who
make 100,000 I feel are are poor and I
don't mean to insult poor people or rich
people or anything like that but I find
it just hard to live even as a
millionaire I'm like how do people live
I I don't know how it is in London it's
super expensive in America uh and so the
only way you can actually be able to
have freedom to be able to make choices
where you're not sweating this stuff
start a
business and then yes get to some point
where it's enough and then you can share
it with other people like one of my
yearly goals this has been a yearly goal
every year is to spend all the money on
myself or others or donate
it and what it forced me to do was like
okay I can't keep this like there's the
book die with zero which I know you like
I have to spend it on others yeah I have
to get someone a nice gift like so I'm
going and seeing
oh this will come out later I'm going to
give some Rolexes to people oh nice that
I'm like yeah think could be a very
generous gift for them they'll be like
holy [__] or um I wore this Rolex
because I got my girlfriend pregnant and
so I said once I finally get not someone
pregnant like that but I would me and my
two best friends would all have matching
Rolexes and this was our dream so now
all three of us have women and we have
we're all have uh our women are pregnant
or have kids and it's just like a
special thing for us and that's just
having that goal that I you can every
year it's in my goal list like spend all
the money on myself or others or donate
it and so these are some examples of
having the money makes it easier and
exciting to go and do that stuff what
are the U for you what have been the I
guess annual income step changes in like
your because so so if you're earning 10K
a 10K a year yeah presumably pretty
miserable when you earning 40K you're
sort of not living living it up 100K
500k a million 3 million what can can
you remember like what were the
meaningful numbers that changed your
life circumstances in way that actually
made you happier I think I was miserable
until I was about 40 not miserable like
super horrible but just never not really
appreciating how good life is and not
much has changed except my mentality
okay so it's t about the money and more
about the way you've approached life
well and it's the thing that's crazy and
I keep saying this is that it's not
exclusive yeah it's available to
everyone and you know one of my good
buddies tinan he talks about he's like
the person you are and the person you
want to be is a lot closer than you
think M like you're probably 99% there
and there's just like 1% of things you
want to change and if you zoom out on on
this person you you are today you can
just zoom out on where you are today you
me everyone frankly lik's already pretty
[__] great yeah we have running water
yeah if someone if someone's watching
this life is pretty [__] it comes out
of a [__] faucet you literally do
this and like where does that water come
from no one knows yeah and it's amazing
we have electricity I every day I plug
in my laptop I'm
like that that whole electricity thing
whoever that Thomas Edison guy or some
woman who invented it God bless them so
just taking a step back life is already
so dope if we can just accept that and
where we want to be with it's money life
we're much closer than we even realize
if we get going now in terms of my
income I'll tell you my salaries exactly
so I graduated 2004 uh Intel I made
55,000 then Facebook I made 65,000 then
I went to Mint and I made 100,000 then I
started my own company so I went down
yeah then I started making 40,000 40,000
75,000 120,000 300,000 then I started my
own company went down to
zero uh so AB with zero 40 75 120 and
then about six years into appsumo I
noticed that I just didn't have anything
to show for it and meaning that a lot of
if you're starting certain companies in
Tech space you want to sell your Equity
go public liquid I was like I don't ever
want to do that that's not my interest
but I don't really have that much in the
bank that I'd feel comfortable and
candidly I felt a little I felt I felt
it was hard to to take the money when
I'm like there's other people in the
company who are doing the work the only
difference was I started and so how do I
how do I balance making sure they're
taking care of and then I'm taking care
of and what I I feel is right and so uh
about six years into appsumo started
paying myself half a million Y and then
the past every year it's been seven
figures so like one to three million and
that but to be clear that's only if we
make money so when Co happened we had
about a one and a half perc profit
margin so I made less than a million um
and that was about two years of that
yeah and so this year thank God it's
been an amazing year it's going to be a
few million dollars inside which is
blows my mind and so
this is not Rel relevant for everyone
else necessarily but when I I didn't
actually feel that I had money until I
had $3 million cash uh in the bank or
like liquid liquid yeah totally
arbitrary and my father started his own
copier business he sold copers door to
door yeah I don't even know if we have
copers anymore you I haven't seen a
copier in a while and he built a
business and through his own choices
like did a lot of drugs and did a lot of
alcohol and lost his entire business and
I remember just as a kid uh feeling
really scared of doing the same thing
where oh I'm drinking or I'm doing drugs
like I'm definitely going to ruin all
these things I've created and so at that
point when I had just the cash and I
have like a disproportion amount of cash
in the bank uh because I wanted if
everything ends like I want to be able
to survive and so at $3 million cash I
felt like okay I can survive the rest of
my life
safely if I if I think of myself like
six years ago before I started the
YouTube channel before I started my
business I would have been like 10 years
ago damn I'm old um something like an
extra 2K a month would have meant like
the entire world cuz when you're making
like zero or like 3K a month an extra 2K
it's like whoa I'm practically doubling
my salary and now I can like go on that
vacation or now I can buy MacBook Pro
instead of MacBook Air or whatever the
thing might be um but then as I grew the
business more and more that number
obviously changed yeah but now I'm sort
of in the same Bullock as you are where
like I'll probably take on maybe two and
a bit million this year and I feel like
that's more than enough that's more than
enough like million goes into the S&P
like you know I've got a bunch of rental
properties oh sorry to hear that I know
it's awful it's
actually I hate it this is a real like
first world problem um
but they're still part of me like every
now and then when I speak to someone
like Sam and Shan who have such
conviction that like yeah you got to go
for 10 million I'm like huh no are they
are they am I missing something that
these guys understand because for
example you and I are telling people
that like you should make more money uh
and and and get up to 3 million and
someone listening to this or watching to
this might might be thinking bro how
could you 3 million I'd be happy with an
extra 10K yeah and so but we're like
that person's missing something because
they don't know how great it is to be at
3 million so are Simon Sean like just
like not missing are we missing
something by not being in the tens of
millions a year in terms of income is
like I I guess something that I I think
about I think most of the people that
are saying bro I'm not at like a g even
right their bigger problem is not that
they're not at a million they're they're
sweating the million or the 10g but
they're not even getting a dollar that's
the big holdup is that they got to get
going is that 13 years ago I made zero
yeah and then I made 40 and then I made
75 and then it was like flat and then
eventually it's like holy [__] like I
can actually make Ser money but it's
realizing I got to get started now
thinking about a freedom number y so I
can actually do the work I really want
to do which was promoting software deals
it's I love it I can't believe this I
literally canot believe my life I got
hang out with you get write a book get
to do a YouTube channel we promot
software and like in LA like this is
unbelievable and it's not exclusive
there's not some club that I got access
to that no one else can yeah I did have
advantages that like some people do and
some people don't but it's like if you
people get going have their freedom
number get there and it's like huh
actually I I've experimented having
maybe a nicer bicycle or maybe a nicer
guitar or maybe they go on nicer
vacations they're like yeah I want this
all the time yeah not when you're 60 I'd
rather be rich at 40 than Rich at 60
which is what my parents are and which
most people are it's like all right I'm
going to work hard save a bunch of money
and then maybe I'll get one like economy
plus seat when I'm 65 it's like pretty
good yeah it's it's not bad it's not bad
but like the live flat seats you know
and you can spend a little bit more
money and enjoy yourself yeah I'd rather
have that at 40 yeah and so just getting
going is that person's problem not
actually I I think it Millions if you're
making a few million dollars a year you
don't have any problems maybe you have
some like mental stuff about happiness
and contentment but like you can go to
therapy do different other experiences
and other ways of actually just
recognizing how great life actually
is this episode of Deep dive is being
very kindly sponsored by TR trading 212
now investment and trading can seem
pretty complicated especially if you're
a beginner I've made a bunch of videos
about this and the thing I always
recommend is to just invest in lowcost
Broad stock market index funds which you
can actually do completely for free with
trading 212 it's a great app that lets
you invest in stocks and shares and
funds completely for free and what I
love about trading 212 is that it's also
got a bunch of really helpful features
that especially if you're a beginner to
the world of investing it can help you
kind of learn the ropes without actually
putting money at risk you can actually
trade initially with fake money and you
can see how you would have performed
without actually putting real money on
the line and then once you're ready to
put real money in you can always switch
to the real trading interface the other
cool feature that I really like is pies
and auto investing so pies are different
like allocations of stocks and shares
and funds that various people on the
internet have come up with and some of
them are even like professional Finance
people and then if you want you can just
copy and paste someone else's allocation
of funds and stocks and shares into your
own account so you can benefit from
other people's experience without
actually having to do any research for
yourself obviously the thing I always
recommend is to just invest in index
funds but if like I do you like to play
around around with like 5 to 10% of your
portfolio with individual stock picking
the pies and auto invest feature is
great for that there is also support for
multicurrency accounts which is
absolutely amazing so if like I do you
invest loads of money in the S&P 500
that is a US fund and normally when you
invest in US funds at least from here in
the UK you're hit with all sorts of
Foreign Exchange fees and all that stuff
and so the fact that trading 212 has
multi-currency accounts means that you
can trade without getting hit with all
these various fees if you have an invest
or an Isa account then trading 212 gives
you a bonus as well which is interest on
uninvested money the interest is paid
out every day and you have full
flexibility there are no minimums or
ceilings and you can withdraw the money
literally whenever you want they've also
just launched a new offer of 5% yields
on GDP 4.2% on euros and 5.1% on US
Dollars and many more currencies through
qualifying money market funds with over
24,000 reviews on trust pilot trading
212 is an amazing platform to get
started with investing so if you click
the link below in the video description
or in the show notes that will take you
a page which will give you instructions
on how to sign up and when you sign up
you'll also get a free share which is
worth up to100 so it's free money and
there's no reason not to do it thank you
so much trading 2 for sponsoring this
episode and let's get back to it by the
way in case you haven't heard my brand
new book Feelgood productivity is now
out it is available everywhere books are
sold and it's actually hit the New York
Times and also the Sunday Times
bestseller list so thank you to everyone
who's already got a copy of the book if
you've read the book already I would
love a review on Amazon and if you
haven't yet checked it out you may like
to check it out it's available in
physical format and also ebook and also
audiobook everywhere books are sold I
really like this this idea of and
experiments um like in in my book the
whole thing is like try this experiment
in your life and see what happens and
back in the day when I was kind of torn
between do I do I do parttime medicine
and parttime YouTube and and stuff I was
like oh why don't I just run the
experiment and so I ran the experiment
for a few weeks I did part-time medicine
parttime YouTube and I realized I don't
like doing parttime
medicine um and then I had a I was
interviewed on Louis House's podcast and
he talked me out of ever going back to
Medicine cuz pretty good show yeah
because I I you know we were talk about
passive income and stuff and then I said
to him like yeah you know I like the
idea of being a doctor part time and he
was like why and I was like oh um cuz
like security and stuff and he was like
really like how long would it take you
to make 100K a year if you lost
everything right now and I was like oh a
year or two and he was like I'm sure you
can do it like six months I was like
yeah I probably could and it was like he
really challenged me on that and help it
helped me realize that actually I'd been
Clinging On to this story that I needed
to be a doctor part time even though I
had run the experiment and even though I
knew results of the experiment we like
uh I actually don't enjoy this yeah but
now I take a more experimental approach
to think where where I'm like you
know what is like experimenting with I
don't know this is going to sound super
out of touch but like airnb versus Hotel
what's actually nicer turns out I prefer
hotels because you get everything done
for you and that's cool I realize I like
convenience but actually economy Delight
on Virgin Atlantic is just as good as
business class there's no need to pay 15
grand for upper class when you can get
economy Delight which is like $300 extra
compared to economy and it's just as
good and I'm like oh that's great I've
now save 15K ver my fly version Atlantic
so it's like I'm running these sort of
mini exper this is these are dumb
examples but these mini experiments in
my life to be like does spending more
money on thing X actually improve my
happiness with thing X or can I just not
do that and still be totally content
exactly I'm getting more and more of
this data over time well and I think
this applies not just to there there's
two separate things if we take a step
back you're saying there's one about
enjoying creating the money and the
second part that we're talking about is
enjoying your money yeah and this part
no one talks about because most people
are still trying to to create it yeah
it's also very unfashionable to talk
about how to enjoy money once you're
already rich and this and what the
reality though and I think what you're
commenting on is actually really
interesting this is super powerful how
do you when you do an experiment yeah
and it fails you don't say like I'm
going to give up and blow this whole
thing up you what do you what do you do
you learn from it and you're like try
another one yeah and so if people start
thinking all right if I want to start a
business I want to be an entrepreneur I
want to get this great investment maybe
I don't want to make Be A Millionaire
maybe I just want to enough for
groceries maybe I want enough for seed
upgrades or maybe they want to be able
to go to a nice meal when you think of
it as an experiment you're not putting
so much pressure on yourself to succeed
yeah when you experiment you say I am
going to try to do a cookie business or
I'm going to try to start lawn care
business or I'm going to try to start an
accounting business whatever it is a
software business doing invoicing
whatever when you experiment and it
fails you're like all right well that
didn't work H this or this video didn't
work what what can I learn from it
you're not so pressured oh I'm a failure
like no it didn't work okay let me go
back and experiment and again and again
and again and again and it's through
this process which we I cover in the
book as well most of the most successful
people have experimented the most yeah
think about that most of the most
successful people have experimented the
most they've done these things and a lot
of the things did not work yeah I've
done conferences I've done discount
cards I've built a lot of software no
one's ever seen yeah I've done so many
things that no one's ever seen because
no one wanted it same and so but I'm
experimenting I keep at it and
eventually that's led me to find
something like appsumo that thank God
has worked and I've been able to help a
lot of people employ people and all
these things but it's through the act of
going at it starting it and just again
and again like Shawn like Sam these guys
have done things and tried it it didn't
magically just happen overnight yeah
yeah like from age 13 to 19 every year I
haded one or two new business ideas I
did affiliate marketing sites I did um
pyramid scheme trade doubler kind of
this was back in like the 20067 era I
tried starting my own web design studio
I tried making an online video game I
tried contacting Nintendo to be like can
I build an online version of Pokémon cuz
I was learning how to program at the
time I was like 14 years old um did they
say yes no they were like [__] off
basically uh I built a forum where I was
like super into these books of these
kids who are spies and I built a forum
that was like we're going to teach you
how to do lockpicking and martial arts
and stuff so if you're a kid you can
learn these skills and I I did all this
[__] when I when I was in school and
then the first thing I did that actually
succeeded was when I was like 19 and was
like why don't I apply all my skills of
web design to this idea to to the fact
that I know how to teach and I can I got
into med school to build this courses
business around helping people get into
med school which then was making me like
40K a year in profit while I was while I
was at University which led to my
YouTube channel all of it sort of
happened and even then like we had like
a dozen acquisition channels for this
courses business all of them were crap
except when I started making YouTube
videos that was the only acquisition
Channel we had apart from spamming on
forums that actually got a sales I was
like oh this YouTube thing is good I
should I should stick at this YouTube
thing so even like if someone looks at
my stuff now they're like oh he's a big
YouTuber whatever but they don't see
like the literally 15 years 16 years now
of experimenting and trying random [__]
and throwing stuff at the wall and
crucially I think and I really like your
point about this I was having so much
fun along the way could not get I could
not wait to get home from like a day of
lectures in med school to like Tinker
away on the website of my of my courses
business I couldn't wait to learn like
PHP backend programming so I could s sit
up with my brother pair programming like
this medical school question Bank in
like 2015 and when I was home for the
holidays that was so fun it was so
exhilarating and if you can find find
that thing and get started with it in a
way that's actually fun I think it's the
fun and the enjoyment that that sustains
you on the journey and eventually
something will succeed of course it will
it's it's not not going to succeed but
as you say way too many every everyone
either struggles to start or they just
quit way too early exactly hey this a
good stuff so what else is in the book I
feel like we we we've just like vaguely
scratched the surface um
no there's a lot in the book there's a
lot you've gone full Ham on like 1 12200
beta testers like beta testing every
chapter and making sure it's only the
good [__] I'm so inspired hearing I was
intimidated hearing about your beta
testing strategy I was like [__] we're
not doing that for Rob yeah I mean
taking a step back I think one of the
cheat codes for anyone out there is how
do you how do you buy or copy or steal
the 10,000 hours from other people yeah
everyone's heard it right but I don't
have 10,000 hours to go be a doctor I
don't have 10,000 hours to be the
greatest writer in the world I don't
have 10,000 hours to be the best
YouTuber in the world so how can I pay
to get someone else an affordable price
to be able to help me with these things
and so this is available you know you've
had different business coach is on so
for this book I wanted you know and let
me tell you that the origin story of the
book because I think this is applicable
for everyone out there 15 years ago I
said I wanted to write a book and a few
years ago I was like all right well I'm
I'm just gonna write a book because
that's what you do I started and I sent
it to an agent named Lisa demono she's
uh rem's agent's agent she uh rem's your
a thiago's agent James clear's agent I
believe and I sent her the proposal and
she laughed at me she's like this is not
a real proposal like come back when
you're serious and this is like you know
top Top Class agent and everyone could
relate to that you know you do this
thing and you get rejected and and it's
like how do we have courage to face fear
and that's what courage is it's being
afraid and doing it anyways that's
courage and she rejected it and and all
these rejections whether you know we
teach you through the book every
rejection is just a test if you want
something oh every rejection is just a
test if you want something 100% okay do
you really want it and so when she
rejected me I was like yeah I want this
book there's nothing else out there like
it that helps you overcome your fear and
helps you get the the business actually
started and then growing and so then
talk about cheat codes I started hiring
10,000 hour people so I found the guy
who wrote James's clear book proposal
David M oh yeah I worked with him in
mine yeah and so I he ripped mine to th
M to shreds he took what I read wrote
and then laughed at it deleted
everything redid it and then I was able
to sell the book for a ton of money yeah
because I paid a guy who's got 10,000
hours on it after David I then said all
right I want to I'm I'm a pretty good
writer I like making content all these
things but I'm like a blogger Twitter
I'm not a real storyteller author let me
find the best in the world and so I went
and looked through all the best business
books in the past decade and there's a
guy who's written two of them his name
is to robs here so he wrote Never split
the difference and also what else did he
write uh Never Eat Alone Oh I haven't
read that I've heard good things
phenomenal okay nice this book was
called never be poor That was cuz he
likes never or never be poor in a
weekend no but uh never be poor why did
you not call it never he has like never
in his title uh and so it was basically
trying to I I cold emailed him yeah just
like anyone else can and I said hey I
wrote this proposal took me a year to
write the proposal and again these are
just things that people can think about
all right so I got going it didn't work
but I still wanted it I wanted it I
passed the rejection test I had you know
then I was like all right I spent a year
writing the proposal and then with tall
I was like I want you to write this book
with me whatever it takes and so I was
able to work with him to then write this
book and then uh it's like all right how
do I do this in other aspects of my life
whether it's a business coach or Moody
for marketing or CEO coach like go find
some one pay him $1,000 an hour or pay
him whatever it takes and the amount of
value you get is insane out of it yeah
uh and then through the book candidly
and this probably will come across I'm
not supposed to do this I'm supposed to
be like super confident like I've
started all these businesses I've got a
lot of confidence it's like no I'm
insecure just like everyone else
everyone else out there everyone has
some insecurities or lack of confidence
and with tall in this book I said all
right well I've started a bunch of
businesses and a lot of them made
millions of dollars and I've worked for
Zuckerberg
start.com I was scared of writing the
book because I was like I don't know if
it can really help people so let me me
give the book to tall we went we went we
went for a week in the woods which is
kind of weird uh two guys that didn't
know each other two bald Jewish dudes he
and then I was like he's just going to
write the book and do everything and
then hopefully it's good and it'll help
people yeah and all of us have a hero's
journey inside of us and I was just so
afraid of the book just like appsumo I
was afraid that I'll ruin this company
as well and I thought he would just save
me which I think a lot of us do like all
right I'm not going to try this thing
out I'm not going to try the business
out I'm not going to try the the job out
I'm not going to try this relationship
out cuz afraid afraid of what action can
become which is amazing we realize that
there's some level that you can be on
that's [__] awesome and as we working
on the book I realized like I had to
face my fear of can I actually help
people or not even though I've done it
myself even though I've hired literally
the best writers in the world got the
best publishing company the best agent I
don't know if this going to work I'm
really afraid and that's what led me to
then build the beta team which is
basically like thousands of people so
every chapter had 20 people go through
every single page 10 chapters 20 people
for chapter and they're like yeah this
is this is crap here's what we like now
not how we like that we don't understand
this this doesn't make sense then I
started baited every weekend we baa test
with five people so I just got off
there's a guy William there's a guy LG
there's a guy Felipe he's a he's a
developer he wanted to start developing
business and I was like okay let's go
through the book all right you're afraid
of you're afraid of starting let's go do
the coffee challenge wait where you're
like on Zoom calls with these guys we're
doing our WhatsApp groups oh wow so
every weekend there's you but every
weekend there's different people going
through their own million dollar weekend
experience so I can understand wow if it
actually will help them or not that's
insane and so every weekend for six
months now and then until the book
launches and maybe afterwards we'll do
it I wanted to build a book around will
this actually help people change their
life and start a business which
literally you can change your life in 48
hours that's pretty [__] nuts yeah
and it's available for everyone it's
pretty nuts it is nuts and so through
all of us it's realizing that we can
face our fears and overcome hard things
and through doing this book helping
thousands of people now literally just
this book not not all the business I've
started which has been a lot not through
working for Zuckerberg not through all
this stuff it's like oh wow it actually
works and so that's been the part of
building my own confidence then to come
out here be like dude this book if
people actually want to change their
life start a business I'm excited about
a million dollar weekend so I don't feel
like I have to go sell it I feel like
it's my responsibility to tell people
like we're talking coming back full
circle I'm like yo if you were trying to
change your life in a weekend if you
don't like your job or you want to
create your own job you actually
can so you're going to be a dad fairly
soon I'm going to be a dad in July which
is insane yeah how how has that changed
your approach to I guess work and life
180 okay first off it's made me have a
lot more admiration for moms we have at
Absol when I started we didn't have
health insurance for 5 years it was just
like stay inside don't leave your house
so you'll stay healthy I mean that was
that was our health insurance plan
because we couldn't afford it
yeah we have moms at EP suumo and I have
so much respect for them the fact they
can they show up at work and they do
amazing jobs like and they're pregnant
with it as well as moms and families I
have a lot more respect for how hard it
is uh my my girlfriend is going through
like morning sickness and all these
things and she still has to go to her
own day job yeah and so that that's been
a first part just like wow a lot of
admiration for families and especially
the people who are birthing I'm like
holy [__] this is tough secondly I would
say the 180 is how much time we waste we
[__] around so much and being a parent
to me and being you know with this book
being in a company being whatever it's
like are you showing up like you say
this is your priority but this is your
behavior is your priority and behavior
actually aligned and I've been noticing
with my girlfriend she's been saying hey
I need you finishing at 6 and I'm like
dude I I dig around at work till at
least seven or eight you know and it's
been a great 180 and a great blessing
that I want to be available for my
family I want to be able to show up on
time I want to prioritize what I say as
my priority which is my girlfriend and
our baby yeah and so how do I adjust my
schedule and my what I'm working on so
that I do the most important things and
really finish on time I think everyone
should think about the pregnancy hack
just imagine your your husband or wife
and your family you're about to have a
family and you don't have a lot of time
I am much more selective what I'm going
to be doing who I'm going to be doing
with and making sure I finish on time
and as well being an entrepreneur I can
have a lot more flexibility in that I
don't have to go to my day job I don't
have to worry about a three-month
maternity plan I could take a 12-month
that's what I really want to do with my
family but just changing my perspectives
on time it's much more intentional
because I want to show up
I really like that yeah this something
I've been thinking about a lot like
um one thing that I would I would I
would like to be the sort of person who
prioritizes relationships over work and
so there have been a few occasions where
my girlfriend has needed me for
something and in that moment I was like
set up for filming a YouTube video and
that YouTube video would have made 20
grand in sponsorship revenue and I was
like at that moment of Crossroads
decisions my default is to do the work
thing but the sort of person I would
like to be the the person I aspire to be
is someone who values relationships over
work and so recently over the last few
months I've been making the decision to
be like screw the YouTube video I'm an
entrepreneur I can do what I want like
the whole point of getting to this point
where I have freedom is so that I can
literally give it to the people who I
love and to my family like that's
literally the point um and like you know
I was uh that was there was there was
thing
where I was I was going to like I was
going to go home for the go home to see
my mom for dinner or something and my
car had broken down and like the public
transport wasn't working and then I was
like oh you know I can't I can't go to
see my mom for dinner then I was like
wait a minute let me just Uber it and I
was like $200 to get an Uber to see my
screw it I've I mean that's literally
the point the whole point of making
money and doing all this stuff and
getting all this freedom is to be able
to then cash in for the things that you
actually care about yeah and I I I enjoy
catching myself now in moments where the
default conditioning of save money or
like do work or like work harder or do
this thing actually no I could film
another YouTube video tonight or I could
go to the gym I also value my health
more than work so let's just do that um
whereas in the past I definitely would
have been like oh no but like I need to
build a business in like one more video
now I feel like I'm changing that and
more like valuing health and
relationships how old do you know 29
you're going through like decades and
years man I feel like you're on your
40th year only cool people that I
interview I always learn from people
that's why I'm questions that possibly
half this interview people can't relate
to but like I I want to know the answers
to these question I think a lot of them
can relate to I think a lot of them can
recognize like hey if I want to be at a
place where I can do whatever it is that
you want to do in your life that is
starting now so when you're 25 or 35 or
55 whatever that is 45 yeah you can be
there yeah and I I do think it's
relatable hopefully we'll see no and and
what I say about that is there is a bi
there's a success bias like I'm already
so far removed from being like you know
having a $ 55,000 job dollar job living
at my mom's house to now having my own
crazy house which I can't believe yeah
your house is sick unbelievable
but it was it was getting going on these
things and realizing like huh in my 20s
I definitely I was just I was working
really hard and I think that's great I
think you work if I had to break these
decades down because I'm in my 40s and
I'm finally [__] happy I would say
like actually content yeah I'd say 20s
is just like you're suffering you're
grinding you're uncertain you're
frustrated you're angry at your parents
maybe you're one of the Chosen Few
people that that have like actually like
figured it out but IID say in my 20s I
was just like I don't know living on
floors for a year like I told you going
to Argentina going to Thailand for
months at times and then 30s I'm like
okay I finally found work I I like doing
which is promoting stuff on appsumo but
like I'm not figuring out this dating
part I didn't realize how important
partner selection is I just dated
whoever I got not got who I
want that's the same thing with asking
if you don't ask you don't get you just
hope for something instead of ask and
get what you want and so 30s you kind of
dial some of these things in and 40s
you're calm you're calm you're like okay
okay do I like being with my partner yes
I love being with my partner I love
she's awesome partner but I finally took
time to go to I went to Stephanie rig
it's a relationship coach okay and I go
to therapy and I've hired other dating
coaches and doing these the work of
understanding myself to be there and
then the same thing with my actual
professional life it's like okay I don't
like some of this stuff how do we
finally get more calm and clear on it I
think in the 20s it just feels more
frantic and I'd say overall for everyone
out there there's really two components
of this whole journey that we're all on
on a planet which is Bonkers one is
patience we're so I'm so impatient I was
impatient to get rich I was impatient to
have a kid I was impatient it's like
dude just chill out it'll all work
out but we're we're all rushing to
somewhere which is going to be the death
which everyone ends up at so just be
patient before you get there and enjoy
all these things and I'd say the other
part that I would I would recommend as
well is just be generous to yourself be
generous to yourself be generous to
others and if we can just do a little
more of that you just a little bit more
generous like okay no you're doing okay
today all you're doing okay today you
you're doing okay today yeah be patient
guess what it it does work out it really
does and I think in these moments where
it's not we're we're feeling frustrated
and cre making it such a worse situation
no me that's was a great place to end
this um thank you so much thank you so
much for the advice and all the
inspiration and mentorship over the
years um pleasure last question what
would you like I'm 29 I'm going to turn
30 in about six months hoping to get
married maybe sometime next year to have
kids maybe soonish after that um any
advice put on some
that's my advice nice that's good and so
let me let me unpack that a bit I got to
meet suria he was on The Apprentice you
remember the show The Apprentice like a
we had a UK version of it as well yeah
yeah same thing and um I was 25 we were
at like a Denny's in the Bay Area and he
was on The Apprentice I like oh you're
on The Apprentice so cool and he worked
for Neutrogena the skare company yeah
and he was like put on sunblock and and
try to lotion and wash your face every
night oh nice I was like okay we'll do
that and now I have a skincare routine
which actually was one of the most
popular emails I've sent in the past two
years oh no way yeah that's one of my
most popular videos in the last few
years dude I'm say SK yeah I think
what's interesting for you turning 30
and for everyone else out there it's
kind of what we're talking about million
dollar weekend which is you know
following the
process I started when I was 25 I got
started right now so when he told me
that I went home and I bought Neutrogena
the the roller I still have it in my bag
yeah and I started putting it on and at
41 it's like my skin actually looks
pretty good it looks pretty good looks
like you had a skin yeah I mean I you
know and I was out all day at the ners
game yesterday it was a it was a full
day and but the reality was I I I
started something and I stuck with it
for a long period of time and it was
something small like putting on sunblock
yeah and so for yourself you know what's
the thing you're starting now that when
you're 40 you're like oh I'm glad I put
on some
sunblock think it's working out yeah is
that working out yeah I think it is I
think it is that it is that I've been
kind of doing it on and off but not but
not consistently for years like forever
what do you think's holding you back or
I'd never quite taken it seriously in
that when it was a choice between
working out and work I would choose work
because I was building and I was like
work was more fun than working out and
when I was feeling lazy and low energy
I'd like oh I'll just work on a YouTube
video or whatever rather than go down go
to the gym but put in that extra effort
um but I've decided after attending a
Tony Roberts event um which I know that
you're not a fan of but I decided that
like my top goal for 2024 was to get
into the best shape of my life so that
not so that I can get into best shape of
my life so that a I could experiment
with what it's like being in super super
good shape to see if I want to but more
importantly to build a habit of working
out because I also read outlive by
petera and I was like oh [__] I need to
get started while I'm relatively young
to build the foundation of muscle and
course strength and stamina and
flexibility and all that stuff so now
working out regularly what do you think
that would give you if you in shape and
you're working on all the time just
Better Health and Longevity for the long
term which is kind of what I'm going for
and I'm trying to find a way to make it
fun and then what do you what would be
fun like how could you make enjoy
because this is true for all everything
we talked about we talked about being
rich all these things it's just not fun
because today they have to start and get
going and then in five years or 10 years
or one year they'll be millionaires or
fit or whatever those things are they
have to create a fun environment which
is in the book I'm like okay I'm going
to make it fun so you do get going and
get start and keep with it but like what
would be fun for you in terms of
exercise what has been fun um I quite
enjoy going to the gym on my own
listening to an audio book while I'm
doing it not like trying to go yeah I
just realized this I I don't like it
when I have to work super hard because
then I'm like sweating and it's like
huffing and puffing and stuff but you
know doing it at my own pace still going
to sort of failure or nearly failure on
on the sets that I'm doing um but just
taking my time with it a bit more and
treating it as more like an enjoyable
Pleasant activity rather than oh [__]
I've got half an hour I need to try and
out the workout I Poss can and so I get
I get through a lot of AUD books and
stuff and sometimes I film myself and
put turn into Instagram real of like
working out trying to get that Lululemon
or gym shark sponsorship or whatever the
have you not got the gym shark thing yet
yet we all my clothing is Lululemon now
so I might reach out to them get get
them I I guess even taking a step back
there yeah what would make it fun though
like so what I mean by that this is
something I've learned in my like late
30s 40s like I don't enjoy I used to go
to the gym and it literally feels like a
jail it's like okay so I go to this
place and I literally I'm picking up
something and I just put it back down
like my workout like that makes no sense
to me yeah like that's not fun like I
don't want to go to a room filled with
other people and and be trapped and so I
was like okay well how do I do get the
the outcome I want which is to be
healthy but I do it an enjoyable way so
what are other ways for you I can I can
share mine for me it was like okay I
like cycling because I'm going somewhere
I'm seeing the world I can do it
everywhere in the world you can do it on
the cheap you can do it expensive okay
that's cardio or something and I was
like I want to kind of maybe be fit so I
started picking up boxing because you
know I'm I don't want to get beat up as
I get on YouTube I'm like oh they're
going to beat me up or something like
that I want to and it's a skill as well
as then you get exercise so I like okay
that's kind of fun that it's actually
not kind that's super fun and then
squash and so oh that squash yeah so I
think with exercising what I've noticed
besides sticking with it and okay maybe
you have audio books how do you do ones
where you're like no one has to ask you
to go do it no one has to convince you
to go do it you just actually want to go
do it maybe it's kickboxing maybe it's
Core Power Yoga downstairs maybe it's
stretching maybe it's whatever and so
it's like how do I change you know same
thing we talk about rejection being a
bad thing how do you make it a good
thing how do you find exercise that's
actually fun not you're convincing
convincing yourself it's fun yeah no I'm
I'm in the process of experimenting so
squash is one of those things to me
where I would I I I don't need
discipline to play Squash but I still
need discipline to go to the gym and so
I want to try Crossfit because I've
heard good things about that I've done a
few yoga classes like I tried kickboxing
for a bit and I need to try boxing
because I've heard good things about
boxing but I'm trying to do some
experimentation to find what is that
thing um but also I think I think almost
everything we can find a way to make it
fun and I would like I I think if if I
can find a way to make lifting weights
of the gym lifting a weight up and
putting it back down again if I can find
a way to make that fun I'm going to be
in shap for the rest of my life because
I might not have access to like a boxing
gym or whatever the thing might be um I
know I'll be fit for the rest of my life
if if that's the case um so yeah just
trying to trying to make it fun have you
tried any accountability Partners yeah
do you know Dan go yeah he's my he's my
fitness coach um so I send him my little
workout every time I and is like good
job how has that helped it's really
useful he we have a call every other
week for 20 minutes he answers my
questions he helps me out a bit he's
really good I'm like yeah you know I'm
traveling so I can't get enough protein
and he's like okay well have you
consider just getting some protein
powder and putting in your suitcase and
I'm like good idea I'll just do that
yeah it's interes like Adam Gilbert my
body.com is similar to Dan uh Adam is
one of my best friends in my
accountability partner for like a decade
yeah and literally before I walked into
the show I was like Adam I'm not
drinking until Thursday
because that that's definitely an outlet
where it's like a hard day and you want
to go relax you have a glass of wine and
it was nice to have that support So for
everyone out there it's like whether
honestly in business as well as in you
know in health and relationships it's
finding coaching and Elite people uh to
support you in these different areas and
it doesn't have to be expensive it can
also be a friend or someone else exactly
yeah good stuff exellent thank you for
having me we'll have so we didn't talk
about picking ideas we didn't talk about
scaling your ideas we didn't talk about
growing your business any of these
things I'll have at millionar
weekend.com
all anyone goes there I'll have a free
thing for them to get all these
different templates resources
step-by-step stuff uh from the second
and third parts of the book damn that's
that's really clever and also really
cool pretty good it's just interesting
because you need to think like hey if
you want more if you actually want
templates videos step by step resources
ni and we we're going to do a book club
video about the book where we expl break
down some of the bits and box are you
really yeah and so the idea is that
we'll take some of the sound bites from
this and use them as to like prop up the
book club video it's coming on 30th gen
yeah cool we will do our best to get the
video out that week Namaste thank no
you've been such an inspiration over the
last few years want want to do whatever
I can to help help support the book and
the amount of beta readers you got I
haven't read it yet but I'm sure it's
going to be [__] incredible the
BET yeah yeah I think that's I was
walking in here with with Isaac who I've
been filming with for a few years and I
love this guy and doing the book and
everyone can create whatever the hardest
thing is for themselves like I think
that's something I've been trying to
think about myself like what's the hard
thing I'm avoiding like doing the book I
was I wanted to avoid it but I had to
face some challenge in my life we all do
and then when you face these things you
realize it's not as hard as I thought
yeah starting a business doing
relationship whatever it is and uh going
into the book it's been amazing and I'm
sure you you've you're experiencing this
well like how many people whatever
you're doing but specifically with the
book how many people want to help us
yeah that's have you noticed that nice
I'm like oh man that's cool yeah and
that's been you know I was working with
this guy Jake on his own business
recently and he was calling people and
and getting his business going using the
million dollar ween process and he's
like yeah these people actually are
buying yeah like yeah dude they well
they wouldn't if they didn't want to
and people want to see you succeed and I
think people need a little bit more of
that in their Liv realizing like you can
help others and others want to help you
win too nice good stuff man thanks every
Bud all right so that's it for this
week's episode of Deep dive thank you so
much for watching or listening all the
links and resources that we mentioned in
the podcast are going to be linked down
in the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any question
questions or any insights or any
thoughts about the episode that would be
awesome and if you enjoyed this episode
you might like to check out this episode
here as well which links in with some of
the stuff that we talked about in the
episode so thanks for watching uh do hit
the Subscribe button if you aren't
already and I'll see you next time
bye-bye